joining us for more on this New York
congresswoman Alise stefanic the house
Republican conference chair
congresswoman thanks for being here
great to be with you Brett you know you
see that front page of the New York Post
and you see these business Business
Leaders reaching out saying help us I
mean it's real for these communities and
they've been dealing with it for some
time well let's take a step back Brett
this is a crisis of the Democrats making
uh we've seen historic surge at not only
our Southern border but at our northern
border as well over 5.8 illegal
Crossings since Joe and took office and
New York including the governor governor
hok and mayor Eric Adams welcomed
illegal migrants into New York State and
into New York City and now they're
reaping the crises that has been created
and the Havoc this is causing not only
do we not have the resources to pay for
this but 82% of New Yorkers say this is
a serious issue in New York state my
colleague on Staten Nicole malakas you
just saw the footage BR this is very
serious they're being housed in our
schools our health care uh facilities
are getting overrun we need to secure
the Border House Republicans have done
that passing the most the strongest
secure the Border package in our
nation's history and yet Chuck Schumer
and Joe Biden fail to act you you
mentioned that 82% that comes from
Sienna College poll 82% of New Yorkers
call recent influx of migrants a serious
problem 51% disapprove of uh Governor
hok's job addressing the influx you know
we talk about immigration and oftentimes
it's used as a cudle by both parties as
a political issue Republicans have done
it many times um is there a way to come
to something around the edges that deals
with this problem directly now and we
have House Republicans have BR as you
recall we passed hr2 it's the border
security package and we believe we need
to secure the border to stem this crisis
and then we fix our broken legal
immigration system as one of the
constituents from Staten Island said
this is not opposition to Legal
immigration it's opposition to Illegal
immigration we need to be a country
based upon the rule of law House
Republicans have done this we know know
what a secure border looks like and
those were the very effective policies
of the previous administration and those
were many of the policies that we
included in our bill yeah but the the
problem is congresswoman you you don't
have any Democrats signed on to that
bill and isn't that a shame isn't that
shameful now you see their back they
need to show courage and they need to
show a political spine to say that this
is a border crisis Joe Biden's policies
are not working our policies have caused
this and actually work with us to secure
the border that bill was on the floor
it's pretty telling that every single
Democrat voted against it and this issue
in New York state when we talk about all
states are a border state all
communities are a border Community the
vast majority of these illegal
immigrants are coming across our
Southern border and yet we're talking
about New York City they're trying to
transfer these to Upstate New York it
has been a disaster and Republicans who
stood strong against that have were
smeared by democrats now you see
democrats backpedaling for those
governors who moved migrants from the
border and transferred them to different
cities including New York um at the time
it was criticized as being a political
stunt now they are feeling the effects
and actually turning the tide here they
are feeling the effects because not only
do they see the polling but we don't
have the fiscal resources New York is a
state that's on the trajectory towards
bankruptcy and we don't have the
resources and what's really interesting
is that this has impacted the rule of
law this has impacted real people's
lives Cathy hokel under her leadership
in mayor Adams they transferred illegal
immigrants to Erie County in Western New
York there were two very high-profile
incidences of vicious rapes and now you
see the Democrat County Executive say he
doesn't want illegal immigrants anymore
when he welcomed them into the community
so this is very much tied into the crime
crisis that we saw in New York state and
voters of all political affiliations
know that this is not working and it's a
crisis that hok mayor Adams and most
importantly Joe Biden created
Republicans speaking of politics turned
a number of districts in New York uh in
2022 if you look at the map it's it's
pretty red is the hope that it's going
to stay that way
in this current uh cycle because
potentially of this issue we're going to
run and we're going to win and you see
that it's not just Republican supporters
we earning votes it's Independents and
Democrats who have seen the failure of
single party Democrat rule yes we flip
those five districts in New York state
we are in a strong position to hold them
and flip more districts because New York
state has failed and Joe Biden has
failed and this ties into the crime
crisis as I talked about you saw the
polling 82% of New Yorkers don't approve
of or they believe it's a serious issue
and over 50% disapprove of how New York
state has handled that so they're going
to make their voices heard at The Ballot
Box congresswoman stefanic we appreciate
your time thank you Brett I'm Steve duy
I'm Brian kilme and I'm Angley aart and
click here to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling
analysis